let's head to springs preserve talking
fall water restrictions with the
southern nevada water authority the
sponsors of this next segment
my name is diana diaz and i work for the
southern nevada water authority and
we're here at the springs preserve to
remind you of the fall mandatory
watering restrictions the mandatory fall
watering restrictions are officially in
effect now through the end of october
which means that you can only water on
your three assigned watering days if you
don't know your watering schedule you
can visit
snwa.com to find your assigned watering
days
it's really important that you change
your watering clock now to avoid costly
water waste fines fines that range from
about forty dollars to eighty dollars or
higher for repeat offenders and to save
money and water
and this year the seasonal restrictions
actually take on added significance
following the announcement of the
shortage declaration on the colorado
river the shortage will reduce the
amount of water we can withdraw from
lake mead the source of 90 of our
communities water by 7 billion gallons
of water next year now if every property
in southern nevada were to follow the
seasonal watering restrictions
year-round our community could save more
water than is being cut under shortage
condition that's more than 7 billion
gallons of water a year
and did you know that by changing your
watering clock each season that's four
times a year to comply with the seasonal
restrictions you could save up to 300
dollars annually on your water bill some
of our best watering tips include for
sprinklers watering no more than 12
minutes per watering day that's all your
grass needs now for drip irrigated
plants you can water less days but for
longer durations
depending on the flow of your emitters
we recommend about one to two watering
days per week for drip irrigation
and you can invest in a smart irrigation
controller
and you can enjoy the ease of setting
your watering clock from your smartphone
from anywhere and the water authority
actually offers a rebate for smart
controllers so you could save money and
water some additional tips to save money
and water are to get rid of your useless
grass if you're only on it to mow it
then replace it with water smart
landscaping the smwa offers a rebate of
up to three dollars per square foot of
grass that you replace with water
efficient landscaping water smart
landscapes can be beautiful colorful
vibrant they're more than just rocks and
cacti and you can get a lot of ideas
here at the springs preserve for your
water smart landscape to help you start
saving time money and water
thank you so the nevada water authority
for sponsoring this segment jc they need
a raider to be their new enforcer right
absolutely all right for more
information call 702 258 save or visit
snwa.com